I doing I'm so confused what happening
okay so what's going to happen is you're
going to leave the air side and then you
go down to the ticket sure sure sure
we'll get rebooked right you want to get
rebooked or no no no no I need
concentrate for a second you're not
going on there do you want to be
rebooked yes or no look at me yes or no
do you want to be rebooked you can't be
on this plan I'm going to ask you one
more time do you want to be rebooked or
no okay let's go so you want
refund you're no longer a ticket of
Passage you have be off why are we doing
this we're going to refund no why are we
doing this guys
I does he need to sign anything or
anything okay come on you're going to
get put your arms down sir walk on your
own behalf you have to leave so my dad
has bladder cancer they will not let me
S to hear that but you can't go on the
plane no no my dad has blood cancer he's
at Mayo and you are not letting me on
the plane this is kind of fucked up man
I got to say they asked you if you
wanted to be rebooked you said no keep
moving keep walking no you got to keep
going you got to leave why are we doing
because that company's not letting you
fly no no guys and when they tell you to
leave hey guys guys guys guys guys you
got to go we we'll talk you can talk and
walk you're not being reasonable right
now talk and walk we're just going to
get you out just
P honest my
dad no we understand that but you you
can't fly today clear it up why why
can't that they're not cuz that Airline
said you could pay attention pay
attention oh what am I do I can you like
we don't want you to fall however you
want no no no get off me
man calm
down you can talk while you walk walk in
that direction walk in that dire listen
keep walking we're trying not to put you
in jail we're trying to get you out of
here but you got to
go guys you go guys what are
we you're drunk and they won't let no
can I throw my shit over
there look a fucking asshole what is
happening you got to leave it's simple
as that listen don't pull your arm away
from me again no no do not pull your arm
away from me again let me have you what
am I supposed to do you want to put your
shoe on I'll let you put your shoe on
but don't pull this is ridiculous guys
listen you created it they won't let you
fly did not create yes you did yeah you
did you're probably a reasonable guy
when we not intoxicated but right now
you're not right this is me you got you
got to be a responsible doll right
you're sure sure right now we're going
to get out the stair side can I can I
please please keep what do you want to
do can I please so hold on he can stick
that stick that back in there put he can
stick it back through stick it back
through so you get your shoe on guys I
swear in my life man listen they're not
going to let you fly so you have to
leave we're trying to get you out of
here without going to jail so try to
trust us on this it doesn't matter put
your shoe on put your shoe on what they
do though you you you're intoxicated
they won't let you they won't you put
your shoe on there you go there you go
grab your stuff grab your stuff grab
your stuff did I do listen we're going
to go without your stuff we grab your
stuff get your
stuff there you go come on let's go keep
walking for you're treating me like a p
no we're trying you're not listening to
us so we're having to direct you and
we're just directing you out now it's
better than going to jail which is
really what you're should what you
should be doing is going to jail and
we're trying not to do that do you
understand that that's that's not true
no it is it's called it's trespassing
and disorderly intoxication it is I do
okay you have someone that can come pick
you up yep there we go we're going to
work on that when we get on the other
side of the the airport right you have
your boarding pass guys why are we doing
this you have your boarding pass
confused you can't F listen they won't
let you fly you can fly tomorrow what
have I done you're intoxicated he's
not I doesn't matter your money's been
refunded to your credit card that used
to purchas ticket you're not flying
tomorrow you can't fly you can fly
the
come don't start don't start doing that
kind of stuff cuz you will you'll just
end up going to
jail why so mad at me we're not we're
not mad at
you you I'm drinking my coffee here I'm
not mad at you sit down sit down what do
I do a seat I have a seat Train's going
to move sit down what I do first of all
you're not even listening to me I'm
asking you to sit down that's what I'm
asking you to do and you're not even
listening to that but what am I doing
wrong you've been drinking you're
trated you're Tres getting through your
head I can smell the alcohol in your
breath oh I back
up United United will not let you fly
you that you're no longer a ticketed
passenger so you can't be on the side so
you're going to be we're going to make
sure you get off on at the main terminal
if you need help to get to your party to
get you home or get to a cab we'll help
you out with that if you try to go back
on the a side you will look at me look
at me if you try to go back to the ins
side you will be arrested for trespass
after warning you understand that I need
to yes or no yes or no do you understand
what am I doing WR if you try to go back
to that you will go to Tres simple as
that what am I doing
wrong private CRA shit I've ever seen in
my life you can only go out there if
you're flying they won't let you fly so
all right here we go we going to go
right out to this door right
here come on it's a Time door so we got
to
go can you
break do you need
help you got to leave man you understand
we have two options here we either
escort you off or we take you to jail we
don't want to do the other option but
you're you're not helping us listen
you're not you're not you're not going
to go very far you're getting ready to
go to jail so stop stop being you're
intoxicated me no we're going that way
go that way no no I'm good here no
you're not you're going no no no I'm I'm
I'm good 105 put your hand behind your
back wait wait let's take this off are
you kidding me no
times we've given you really
happen
holy this is really
happening you need do you have uh
where's your ID at it's probably in here
yeah it's somewhere in
there we're not at all
all
holy keep it up have police Poli right
here ladies and
gentlemen they fucking love it these fat
fucks believeing
ARR sideway door at the shuttle we're
unable to reset it what have I done like
what have I
done hey hold on guys control
control
[Applause]
control 1
bag gate Charlie 39 it's a black roller
bag in the gate
[Music]
[Applause]
area what's up
brother watch
side
or it's going to be a side the shut on
the control
[Music]
121 12941 or
105 hold the
door
133 are there alha I'm coming to the
AL
car